the jurgen experience well this is
what's going on right now where a bunch
of fighters are upset because
logan paul and floyd mayweather just
fought and logan paul made 20 million
bucks and floyd mayweather made 100
million bucks and they're looking at
this like hey
what about me like how come i'm not
making that kind of money
and i think what they have to understand
is
whether you like it or not even if you
are an elite the elite of the elite
camaro usman or
you know pick any style bender some of
the best fighters in the ufc even the
lead of the elite
the money comes from people wanting to
buy your pay-per-view
it's real simple yeah it shouldn't maybe
you know maybe in
a perfect world it's the most skillful
fighter gets the most amount of money
but that's not how it works here in in
the world of combat sports
and professional prize fighting it's all
about how many eyes are going to watch
you and that
[ __ ] logan paul kid has a lot of eyes
on him he's had a youtube channel since
he was 14 years old
he's been on disney shows he's this
controversial
larger-than-life you know internet
celebrity and
people are willing to pay a lot of money
to see if he can box with
literally one of the greatest fighters
that's ever lived in floyd mayweather
hey look
i'm not mad at it yeah and you know what
the best fighters in some of the best
fighters to ever fight
lennox lewis andre ward these guys that
i had the honor of representing
you never hear out of these elites that
they're pissed
like good for them because i think that
they get on a fundamental level
that as human beings we unfortunately
were hardwired to watch the train wreck
we want to see carnage um well we want
to see a freak
and we want it is a freak show that was
a freak show it's a circus
i was looking forward to it i really was
i was so excited before the bell rang
for the first round
it's like going to the circus almost
it's like a dude wrestling
a bear i mean kenny wrestled the video
reminded me of it reminded me of
when uh rocky fought hulk hogan
in one of the rocky movies well the
thing the difference though is that
floyd
first of all you got to give credit to
floyd mayweather for doing that because
it's so crazy to fight a guy 35 pounds
heavier than you
that's so big it looked like he looked
like he was fighting a giant yeah
it was like and and to watch him look
i people have a lot of opinions about
floyd mayweather what he does how he
spends his money
listen the guy's brilliant in a lot of
ways he's tapped into
something that human beings want yeah
and want to see but
i was watching him in the fight the guy
outweighs him by 40 pounds
and he's walking to him yeah walking
right to him with his his
hands up yeah chris was like listen he
is
he is a badass and listen the guy the
guy logan paul
he's got balls to get in there and to do
that how could you ever be mad at that
i mean you could take a step back and be
like oh god what does society come to
and right i mean it's come to watching
the freak show
yeah it's come to watching the freak
show and maybe
not just that because there were some
professional fights on the undercard but
no one's talking about
those you know it's just the the big
fight was the freak show fight and you
want to know what i think that this is
going to continue
until someone somebody shuts these kids
up
and like people want to see now they
want
i think it's the same sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy
that mayweather sort of tapped into it's
like i realize the more i run my mouth
the more i make people
have an emotion towards me yeah love or
hate mostly hate
right mostly they're going to be pissed
at me
they now they want to tune in to see me
lose and that's just as valuable if not
more valuable
than wanting to tune so i think that on
a
on a um
he gets human behavior and human
thinking more than he gets credit for
um i don't you know i'm not here to
weigh in on his life or his lifestyle
because i'm who am i
i'm just another human being but i think
that
same thing is happening with these two
people want to see them lose now and
they realize how
there's currency in that right yeah no
there's a lot of currency in that
it's super valuable people want to see
them get [ __ ] up and
you know we were at the ufc recently and
jake paul was in the audience and the
whole
audience was chanting [ __ ] jake paul
[ __ ]
jake paul and he was laughing and
holding his camera up and
filming it and [ __ ] and dc got in his
face yeah which i love to see
that was so cool but it was like then
the story became
cormier confronts paul and uh look
there's part of me that is like
you spend your life racking your [ __ ]
brains how do i make it in this world
how am i gonna
support my family what am i gonna do to
make a difference so there's a part of
it that i get where people are like
and these two [ __ ] kids what do they
do
what how did they get famous i don't
know they pissed people off
yeah but they got famous first this is
what's interesting they got famous first
and then
it turns out they can fight especially
jake
that kid can knock people the [ __ ] out
he knows how to punch can he knock
fighters out there well we don't know i
mean we we saw ascrine right but
ascribing first of all coming off of a
hip replacement surgery was like
it's a brilliant move right you get a
guy who's arguably the worst striker
in elite mma which is ben asks right and
that's no disrespect to ben askren he'd
probably
admit to that phenomenon right
phenomenal wrestler like elite wrestler
great guy not a good striker you make
him box
it's like the worst thing that he does
and then
jake paul starches him with one punch
but he looked you know you looked at his
body he looked severely out of shape
looked like he hadn't trained for a long
time and then kind of got in good enough
shape so he could compete the guy knows
how to fight and knows how to win
but that's not his sport it's not his
sport at all he just took a good
paycheck
i'd like to see this guy jake paul fight
someone
who's going to fight tyron woodley well
after he fights can tyron woodley fight
can he box i well i know he can punch
he punches really hard but he doesn't
punch like a boxer
he throws big bombs and sets up
takedowns and
you know he can crack though with one
shot he could [ __ ] anybody up but the
thing is like the way he throws shots
he'll throw like a bomb and then set up
a takedown or set up a clinch
he's not a guy who's like going out
there with peek-a-boo style throwing
jabs and hooks to the body that's not
his style
he's never been a guy who boxed he's
been a guy who
uses boxing in mma but he uses
everything
does jake paul beat him you think oh we
won't know until they get in there the
thing about it is he'll be the most
dangerous guy that jake's fought for
sure if jake paul not even close not
even close and no one more dangerous
than tyrone was alright well if he beats
an mma fighter
because they're tyrone's not just an mma
fighter tyron is a
multi he's a ufc world champion and one
of the best
welterweights of all time if you looked
at all the ufc welterweights of all time
he's he's top three he's he's [ __ ]
phenomenal
i think there is something fundamentally
different about mma fighters
fighting a boxer yeah because it's
there's other stuff that you
incorporate into your movement right you
worried about leg kicks
you worried about takedown defense
you're worried about all these different
things you have all these different
variables on your plate now you remove
all those variables
you give tyron a pair of shoes and you
just let him punch
i you know he punches really [ __ ]
hard and when
he doesn't have to worry about wrestling
he doesn't have to worry about getting
us tired
and he can and pick his shots he'll be
the most dangerous guy that jake paul's
ever fought for sure
but um it doesn't necessarily mean that
he wins
and i think jake paul can [ __ ] box if
you look at that nate robinson fight i
know nate robinson didn't know what he
was doing
but the way he landed those punches he
he cracked him and knocked him out
moving backwards
he can he can move backwards and then
plant so he's not he doesn't have
like big wind-up movements like his
brother has more
wind-up shots his brother was throwing
more windmilly
type arm punches jake throws things
straight and hard they're dangerous
much more dangerous here's why here's
why i have
more respect for the older brother for
what he just did
yes he outweighed him by 40 pounds but
he got in there with
perhaps the best fighter to ever get in
the ring i'd love to see
how jake paul fares against someone
similar
in size that is a boxer yeah
well you know what man he's only got a
couple of fights here's how you have to
look at him
look at him like any other guy who only
has a couple of fights
if you saw a guy who's coming up and he
didn't have an amateur career and he's
only had a couple of fights
he'd go man he's got some promises yeah
i know but these guys aren't in it for
the
they're are they in it for the long haul
did you become [ __ ] boxers they're jake
says he is they're in it to become
spectacles but imagine
if this guy gets all the way up to a
world title fight
imagine imagine if he actually works his
way through some professional boxers
that would be remarkable wouldn't it it
wouldn't just be remarkable the [ __ ]
money he'll be able to earn well how
about fighting a recently retired you
know who would [ __ ] him up
right now who would [ __ ] him right now
are you saying andre
because he can't fight andre can't fight
professionally anymore because
he's had some physical problems but
andre is still in shape he's recently
retired maybe he'll get are you trying
to set something up
look at you you're looking away you're
like the worst poker player ever he's
like well maybe
well i just know i know i know
look that's my brother i mean i know
that he's like has he thought about it
he's he's thought about it he's thought
about it he he's thought about it and be
like
we've talked about it recently catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience